when's Remora I do you always read my
question sorry aren't they our question
let's you read yours let me enjoy them
no the New York Times reported in 2012
that one in 30 babies born in the US was
a twin it's pretty high we're more you a
2006 study by Gary Steinman PhD found
that taller women are more likely to
have twins our mom's pretty short she's
pretty sure mom's like 5 feet tall
that's just that doesn't work I hope
we're not like consent oh I don't want
to it maybe maybe that allows for more
space in the uterus
in 2011 researchers in Italy proved via
3d video that twins begin to interact
with each other in the womb as early as
14 weeks we totally did you think what
didn't we talk about when you're in the
womb did you think we were like in a
little bubble and we're like reaching
out to every fall asleep it's unlikely
so yeah we just know what should I do in
position that's get it we definitely
were interactive yeah roughly 40% turns
invent their own languages spoken of
only amongst themselves as soon as the
battery we have our own language a few
words there's a few words would you
remember specifically that one time we
were in the ocean on vacation we were
speaking like gibberish and this woman
came up to us and asked us where we were
from
oh are you from I do and we're like oh
no we're just we're just we're just not
saying anything we'd like to start
talking each other people like like not
even saying anything there's a few words
it's more like a vocabulary sheet rather
than a language other words our language
is Louise spell dl h r IE and it's
social outcast it's mainly just become a
nickname for our dad now identical twins
do not have the exact same fingerprint
ba-da-da yeah well though they have
nearly identical DNA fingerprint
patterns are not based on DNA alone so
we can use our arms reach up as long as
we wear gloves if we're ever gonna kill
anyone we'd be fine a UK study from 2005
found that dressing twins and the same
clothes could cause stigma and social
isolation from the twins peers they were
wearing the same thing now are we
anti-social
like a little vet you like switched
clothes in 4th grade and my mom justice
exactly alike and the kids like went
nuts so we made all of our friends and
based off of that we didn't want to look
identical at all not at all
twins are less likely than non twins to
get married it was true some interpret
these findings to mean that since they
were raised with a partner of sorts
twins have less desire to be married so
many of our friends have said this test
I know my number one boy from will be
like oh you're my favorite person I'll
be like oh your life Sakura favorite
person I also always envisioned that
when I buy a house it would be Benny
you're just so used to like you feel
like you've been in a relationship your
entire life you really do I just don't
want to get married because I don't want
to get married but a sounding okay it's
possible for a woman to have eternal
swings with different fathers some
research just a mini Supercenter
fraternal twins could have two different
eyes yeah yeah totally
Burton can stay alive for up to five
days after sex under the right
conditions
if a woman releases two eggs rather than
the usual one and if she has sex with
more than one man within a five day
window it's possible that sperm from
different men can fertilize each egg
that is the weirdest that's another lot
more fun to explain than when someone's
like are you a twin you like you really
I am let me tell you it also passes yeah
it's like a riddle I feel like I learned
a lot I mean like some of them were kind
of like shocking how many new learned so
much about twins I never I just sort of
knew who I was and now I know so many
more things about things all over the
one I feel like a lot of these are
really interesting don't mess with twins
yeah it's actually when's the martyrs
all right learned a little bit more
about twins but I'm not leaving here
totally aghast they're not wow inside
twins
I love twin
[Music]
you
[Music]